una masacre que deja a todo un país
conmocionado decenas de estudiantes de
secundaria fueron asesinados el viernes
por la noche en este pueblo del suroeste
de uganda cerca de la frontera con la
República democrática del Congo según
Los investigadores los asaltantes
atacaron a las víctimas en sus
dormitorios incendiaron el edificio y
apuñalaron a algunos hasta la muerte una
tragedia que ponen entre dicho la
seguridad interna del país
quiero que los servicios de seguridad
nos digan dónde estaban cuando estos
asesinos vinieron a matar a nuestra
gente
hay seguridad dentro de uganda
cómo es que están dispersos aquí la
policía informó que varias personas se
encontraban hospitalizadas con heridas
críticas y que otras fueron secuestradas
ahora mismo hemos desplegado aviones en
varios lugares para buscarlos y ver si
se podría rescatar a los que
secuestraron las autoridades culpan a
las fuerzas democráticas aliadas un
grupo Rebelde de origen islandés pero
que lleva años lanzando ataques desde
sus bases en la vecina República
democrática del Congo es Entonces al
otro lado de la frontera donde el
ejército comenzó a perseguir a los
atacantes de la escuela